[Musique]
on se croirait presque en Afrique
pourtant nous sommes dans les ivelines
aux eosafari de
toiri le parc zoologique vient
d'inaugurer CIN lodges de luxe pouvant
accueillir de à 6 personnes les
visiteurs pourront ainsi vivre manger et
dormir au côté de Ben Moyo et yabou les
trois éléphants du zoo créer une
destination évidemment c'est c'est
l'objectif mais la raison d'être de ce
projet a d'abord été le renouveau de
toute cette terre d'Afrique et de ce cet
espace éléphant qui passait d'un hectare
à 3 hectares de façon à pouvoir
justement offrir une une un avenir aussi
à nos éléphants et à toutes les espèces
qui qui sont nécessaires pour pouvoir
justement arriver à faire la
reproduction si c'était nécessaire pour
l'espèce qui est une des espèces qui est
les plus menacé dans son état mignon
naturel pour cela une chambre de 14400
m² a été construite pour les trois
éléphants dans cet espace ils peuvent se
reposer la nuit en toute tranquillité et
les visiteurs peuvent les observer en
hauteur en toute discrétion ce bâtiment
on pouvait pas le mettre directement
confoné dans l'enclos des éléphants
puisqueen fait les visiteurs vont
continuer à passer dans l'enclos des
éléphants donc il fallait arriver à ce
que ce bâtiment soit intégré il a été
intégré et pour cela on a on a dégrousi
une bute et on a évacué 15000 m³ de
terre et pour l'inauguration de ce
projet terre d'Afrique le parc
zoologique a fait appel à l'acteur
Antoine dulerry pour devenir le parrain
des éléphants c'est beaucoup de fierté
parce que c'est un animal que j'aime
beaucoup quand j'étais petit j'avais un
petit un petit animal qui était un mon
doudou c'était un éléphant Babar célèbre
Babar et donc beaucoup de gens m'ont
toujours appelé Babar tout le temps même
même adulte puis c'est la cause animale
c'est la cause animale pour moi c'est
très important donc c'est la sauvegarde
des animaux de ces animaux qui
malheureusement sontenvoie d'extinction
côté prix comptait 680 € la nuit pour
deux personnes un tarif qui comprend de
jours d'entrée au parc les repas une
visite privative de la maison des
éléphants en compagnie des soigneurs
ainsi qu'un entraînement médical vous
pouvez d'ors et déjà réserver les lodges
ouvreent le 20
[Musique]
octobre